fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby we're getting skanky at the
end of September kick off oh wow yeah
we're just talking about we're just
talking about it I like keeping the
conversation going as it feels more
there's no cameras well we're gonna be
it's official the boys the final kid are
joining the legionist ganks at skank
Fest that is September 29th through
October 1st excited I'm actually excited
about hanging with those guys and doing
it big Jay's uh special we were talking
about it again you haven't seen it I'm
telling you you got to watch it it's so
funny um and you know you watch specials
I don't watch a ton of specials but big
Jays the other day was on these kids
it was retweeted so many times on my
Twitter feed I was like all right let me
[__] I'm brush my teeth dude it's
so good well he's it's so funny
yeah I'm telling you the name and better
special this year I'll wait Chris rocks
not even close what I did today is after
watching Arizona pull off that heroic
event I was like yeah I got inspired now
Jack got hard to him I just well of
course but I woke up and I was like you
know time for me to be a champion but
then I told you with my help you could
get knocked out I could get knocked out
the problem is that I'm Gonna Be A
Champion I don't know how to apply that
heroic it's like that Raul Jr that Rosa
Junior you know he's 18. yeah and he was
like I'm gonna be Champion under a year
there's nothing wrong with that because
everybody who gets to the UFC thinks a
new world champion that's why you get to
the UC kid though but the people around
should go hey I wish somebody does to me
after my second Pro fight Luke Thomas
that's I met Luke Thomas he's
interviewing me he goes what's next I go
Josh Barnett Frank Mayer and he goes
interesting
hey off camera he was like hey dude you
got it like you're yeah
let's chill like Luke was that guy who's
like let's chill yes my coach like no
let's get this is great the best yeah
smart but so for Rosa Junior he like his
team should be like we love the
confidence this is fantastic chill he
shouldn't be in the UFC
he's too young in 18 18. you can see how
talented he is now maximum remember my
call away came when he's 18 18 19 I
think he's championed by I think 20.
yeah so there's the exception but then
don't rule by the exception no the yeah
because also people are so good now
they're doing everything right he's good
too but his striking is no weird nare a
professional level
let alone a UFC Contender I didn't know
that I can't see that nowhere near he I
think he threw 18 punches total in the
in 15 minutes three of them landed yeah
and then his grappling it's not like
he's an outlier like a you know Bryce
Mitchell or khabib or Bo nickel so if
that's your thing you better be so
exceptional at it yeah in order to get
over the hump of the other Strikers but
he's not there yet and it's all good
dude you're 18. it's all good yes time
to just develop two years but you had 64
years old we teach you some wrestling
yeah well now now don't say we find that
115. brush up on my wrestling and add to
my already I forget you wrestling High
School dude we just already dust off the
old singlet wrist control I know how to
relax I'll get you I take your back I
can crab ride I do a lot of [__]
definitely my opinion that fight the
Cowboys fighting man I was laughing so
hard driving home I was laughing at Sam
this morning I woke up laughing at I
like Izzy's tattoos he's just we're just
all right
we're dead serious dead serious he goes
God I love Izzy's tattoos and then it's
30 seconds of Silence which is usually
frowned upon on a podcast and I just go
silence silence
I have the clipton you have the clip
yeah it's so [__] funny it's very
funny
because the the what makes it funny is
Sam is so sincere he's just like Sam is
awesome oh I love those tattoos yeah
Sam's a high level
just dead silence
yeah Sam's the best man I think if I
fought in UFC I'd have to suck down at
115 and that's what's annoying to me 115
fight females yes yeah that's what
annoys me because I'm looking at Cheeto
one of my kids see this is what I'm
talking about what about
um what about slap Fight League
slot Fight League I don't I feel like we
can get you a deal no I don't have the
uh face for it please let's fix my hair
there anyway dude I love Izzy's tattoos
they're so awesome look at everyone
silent
I didn't really know how to respond
just comedians just everywhere comedians
like hanging with all of us with no
problems I couldn't see that that felt
like
I didn't know what to do without
sounding racist I had nothing you look
cool
that's the hardest ever seen Tim it's
very very uh
just missing the boat here
it came from Sam's Soul yeah me and
cheater were like back in the fight you
guys were dying by the way look at bears
like a little red
alive
yeah the reason why Cheeto fits in so
well is because he's not trying to uh
one up guys you know he knows there's uh
Symphony there and he's not trying to
jump in with the [__] Trump he's
great that's why he's great and he's
funny himself he's smart funny Special
Love Cheeto yeah he's awesome yeah you
said uh I feel you like that guy's gonna
do big things outside doctor I'm a
hundred percent that's why when I'm not
throwing shade on him hopefully it
didn't come off like that but he's like
yeah hopefully when I'm done fine I want
to open up a coffee shop I'm like yeah
coffee franchise I would set your your
goals a little higher my man we'd open
one right now daddy he's one of those
guys he's going to be successful at
anything he touches everyone loves
cheetah he's such a good person everyone
[__] just smart and funny confident
really likes that danger too like he was
saying he goes if there was a if there
was something out there that was
dangerous I'm doing it like that's just
a mindset some people just have that
Daredevil mindset that would not be me
I'm a cautious fella because you're
behind the boys right and you get your
lips ready kitty cat because after the
fight he's singing it off well
I was wrong about Izzy wasn't I well my
heart wanted is he gonna start I I
couched it now if your heart wants it
you can put money on the on the his
opponent piece of [__] well
nobody's ever done what he did it's
important to realize that no one no one
has ever lost three in a row and come
back I just want to show you this just
so people know I'm not
bullshitting here let me show you this
so I was so confident is he gonna finish
this is Izzy
to get it done under two rounds via
knockout
1000 pays 10 grand
we're going to Sizzler damn you made
some money
it's not about the money the point is is
that you just knew I just because I'll
be honest with you when you took Izzy to
be honest with you I thought you were
doing it to be theatrical and I thought
you were doing it because you love Izzy
like I thought I was like okay he's I am
biased I do protect the guys that I like
or have a relationship with I do always
ride hard for it but this one like if
you just look at the tape and you have
any sort of background fighting like man
if Izzy just tweaks a few I know he's oh
and three but if he just tweaks a few
things here especially in MMA he's
there's no reason he should have beat
this guy huh not to assume he's gonna
knock him out
a little far-fetched but also in that
first fight 10 more seconds that fight's
over in the first round yes so is he it
comes from the great Camp probably the
best camp
we could definitely argue it yeah so his
team been having to be able to watch
that footage realizing he was up on the
scorecards almost got to finish dude to
pull off the ropa dope do you think he
pulled the rope-a-dope off because his
leg was getting such a beating or was
that I'm gonna bring him in like he did
last night yeah that's cash bang Bang
Yeah the game plan was get Alex Pierre
to open up throw multiple combo shots to
open up for The Knockout there it is and
that was beautiful because you could see
him literally roll roll you're like what
is he doing wow yes he's just tight
because there's a certain uh distance
there where Pierre's the most dangerous
man in the world but when he's in real
tight like that then Izzy his hands come
down yeah that was so amazing and also
very risky very risky but that heavy
lies That's Heavy lies the crown that's
why he's a champion and that's why he is
going to go down as with the goat or one
of the goats for sure now if he wanted
to overall oh no I'm saying the uh the
middleweight goat oh yeah over I
understand that Anderson's rain is a
little different what about Anderson and
him in their Prime
oh that's tough it is tough because he's
face tougher competition it's just that
but that's not a knock that's why Grace
fall time is stupid to talk about right
Izzy's the greatest middleweight of all
time in
in current times but back then Amazon
was by far Bar None the grace of all
time
and then also the only knock here too I
hate to do it Ashton has some PD issues
so there's that Mark on them the level
of competition for Izzy's a little
higher also Anderson Silva lost to Chris
Weidman never got the belt pack
is he lost and it's unheard of not only
did he get the belt back but he knocked
the dude on conscious and not to mention
the reason Alex Pierre was there is
because Izzy was so dominant not only
has he beat the guy every guy from one
to five in the middleweight division
he's beat most of them twice convincedly
twice so they had to go what are we
going to do oh there's that guy who beat
him kickboxing hey you doing MMA I just
took one dude get one more one second
UFC they [__] zip line this giant
Brazilian monster to the front of the
row and is he's like this guy didn't
earn it like nobody beat Sean Strickland
this he's like who gives a [__] UFC's
like we do you need a competition and
rightfully so because they made a ton of
money that's right so they they beeline
this and it's not because now could he
beat anybody else in the top ten maybe
I'm not going to shame the guy coming
off a loss but they've been way tougher
fights for him no he gets to skip all
that just to get to Izzy because he's so
dominant then he beats Izzy because he's
Izzy's Achilles heel is he's oh and
threes you [__] oh and three knocked out
all three times I believe no no no no
lost one decision two Knockouts yes two
Knockouts two Knockouts is huge though
awful I mean awful huge so he's your
Achilles heel he's the worst matchup you
beat everyone so bad did you go find a
guy who would provide a kickboxer to
fight you and [__] get him to the
[__] clear pass line at the airport
to get to you I don't think people they
do it
he loses but and then he knocks him out
I don't think people realize what what a
knockout does to you psychologically too
somebody might knocks you out twice you
feel that so deeply that's like
terrifying but the the one in the past
is whatever in kickboxing the recent one
in MMA insane now granted it was a TKO
not knockout yeah but it was an early
stoppage but still still and the problem
is you're feeling that you're having
that guy all he can handle for four and
a half rounds and then he would still be
able to win you're like what the [__]
and Izzy beat those odds dude now I know
the Vegas at him is a slight favorite
which I agree with because again to a
trained guy you're watching like man
fizzy just tweaks a few things there he
should beat him nine times out of ten
yeah that was the one time he beat him
yeah Alex is new to MMA people forget
now here's what I think that's yeah
here's what I think and he's gonna
here's the thing that Alex Pierre I like
the guy he's a really good guy too dude
he's gonna dominate light heavyweight
[Music]
triple D does have triple D like your
mom's tit that Uncle if guy is a
wrestler and that might be okay don't be
a party pooper
and collab you're not in this party no
John maybe if you want but Enclave you
just want to wrestle you can't get in
the club dude this is a Striker's only
Club okay all right all right what are
you trying to do dude I'm just saying
this is a party where we we to in order
to get in you got to be a pay-per-view
well you so so you you keep my collab
away from you go to heavyweight don't
collect what your business no good here
are they not gonna give him the fight no
they don't want alcohol I have involved
no no they want to keep it a Striker's
division correct Jamal Hill Striker yeah
hands full with you know who would you
say don't hurt my husband have his hands
full without spear with the Aztec
warrior yeah oh yeah all he that's why
I'm saying he's gonna he's now he had
really good success especially with the
experience at middleweight at light
everybody he's not come that way and
that chin holds up bro good luck to
everybody good luck now okay so we'll do
yeah I'm not to mentioned I'm telling
you right in the life not to mention him
he's dude retired uh we got Jan yeah I
hate to do this you love wrestle right
he's a guest I love to wrestle cool
you're out so we gotta release you
here's your Walking Papers yeah but Yuri
yiri pierra
the poster alone yeah will get me to
make some socks at your crunchy yes it's
exciting it's exciting because Yuri is
going to be striking with him and here
he does that karate stuff he does all
sorts of wild [__] yeah just a poster
alone here it's gonna be a nightmare for
a lot of those guys yeah because he's
gonna be he's going to be dicing your
lower legs small hill is going to be
good yeah Jamal Hills fun up there yeah
Alex Pierre that belt I can see rotating
but it'd be it'd be hard pressed again
if we cut Monument right I hate to do a
stuff yeah we release him we got Nikita
krielof doesn't he do a lot of no
Striker okay yeah Johnny Walker see
everybody else down for the party
everybody else we're dancing to hip hop
man wants to dance classical this ain't
hey we're gonna you know what we're
gonna send you belt door yeah hate to do
this to you you gotta get a belt what we
can't use it let's do it but Uncle if
it's there he's a monster Striker and a
crazy dude like I know just let him get
under hooks he just wants under hooks
he just wants a clinch dude this is a
hip-hop dance you're the weird Russian
staying at the wall refusing to dance we
gotta get you out how do you keep the
number two guy out of the mix I don't
hate to do it
now Jerry's having with his shoulder for
a woman yeah he's out no he he just he
he told out Spirit he wants to fight
so but that shoulder they said Dana says
the worst shoulder injuries he's ever
seen so this means hot second you can
just picture the poster racket has an
injury too that's a problem Anthony
Smith fun one Anthony Smith fun one
let's find one
Johnny Walker super fun you tell me you
wouldn't pay for Johnny Walker without
the air I would
um Paul Craig Grappler sorry bro Walking
Papers is is Alex Pera the highest level
striker in that whole division by far
Yeah Yeah by far not even close yeah
most decorated next one close to him but
maybe Dustin Jacoby
wow
all right
hey
Batman no disrespect but
he's there's no tickets I know like he's
the get the man give the man his do well
you just bench him you're like dude we
hate to do this but this whole Russian
Ukraine thing this one thing the Russian
he's like since when like now we can't
have a DocuSign to take her until that
war is over you're too good until that
War is Over which you're gonna buy us
about three years so that War's over
we're gonna assist you it's a national
security and then you can come back yeah
then we'll come back National Security
yeah you gotta learn some English dude
we just got the polls back people don't
see a fight to the Russian we hate to do
this dude he's like that doesn't make
sense I know yeah
well khabib could be in this corner and
doing all this it'll be three times yeah
just be in there because they
you know there's nothing to do with each
other oh is Demir
a little bit it's the nasty I mean not
us to me I mean uh Uncle I have nasty
Striker nasty although he did lose his
last fight no it was draw and draw
I thought he won that I'm gonna say
nasty Striker I mean definitely good he
he couldn't be more dagestani looking
he is from Pakistan yeah
or somewhere like that
yeah yeah
hey do I hate to do that you just give
the man but he just he's won so many
fights
he's like hey [__] I've won one two
three four five six seven eight nine and
my tenth was for a world title was a
draw you're gonna cut me I'm like I did
it makes no sense
nowitz is going to be a problem for Pera
his wrestling is a nightmare
he like defense himself a striker too
though he'll play that game yeah
he's smart although he'd probably yeah
the same way he did against Izzy he
really didn't test the feed on the Izzy
he took him down Oxford just big two men
those shots I can't wait
oh
you know I hate to do it I do I hate
doing that you do huh I hate it
uh I think you might see on in the 85 I
think you're gonna see they're gonna
find a reason
there oh well here's my question are
they gonna find a reason to jump uh the
chat nightmare up is he gonna fight is
he next no he's gonna fight he's gonna
fight Whitaker he's gonna fight Whitaker
in Winter fights is he
Whitaker wins we got Whitaker who
wouldn't want that yeah people would
like Whitaker right now he's on a win
streak fantastic fighter but him versus
if he be Tom hamzat then you have harmed
the winner of them have his hands full
with Whitaker his toughest match up in
the top ten really yeah Whitaker's no
joke no joke good wrestling you know not
not not homside style but his striking
really explosive has a gas tank knockout
power that Taekwondo in and out style
tough to take down I know about it now
and I know about Taekwondo so I don't
need you to bring that up but thanks do
you want to talk about Jan some more you
[__] I calmed you out Jan black bits
hey you're not very good with names
compared to you um
yeah but when Fighters gonna have to do
it with you General if if it's Jan black
if the numbers got if the names got Z's
in it and stuff oh the Daddy Stand names
I don't even I still have trouble saying
uh khabib
nurmaga made of
yo be careful that is
hey B let's take a little break dude
because I'm in Atlanta this Thursday
Friday Saturday Atlanta Georgia doing
the Dirty Bird baby come get you some
this Thursday Friday Saturday B you're
gonna be in Austin I'll be in Austin
then I'm in uh helium Portland April
20th to the 22nd get your tickets skank
Fest your boys are there September 29th
through October 1st gankfest.com enjoy
this episode the fire kid is brought to
you by betterhelp getting to know
yourself can be a lifelong process
especially because we're always growing
and changing well here's the thing
sometimes you need a professional to
talk to your friends your family are not
going to do the trick you need a
licensed therapist Better Health can get
you connected to a licensed therapist in
48 hours or less okay it's just way it's
not as expensive you're not in a waiting
room it's not awkward you can do it
literally uh from your phone or your
computer or your work or home wherever
man if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help but try it's
entirely online like Brian told you
designed to be convenient flexible
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com fighter
today to get 10 off your first month ten
percent off better help
you spend so much of your time in bed do
you understand a lot of sleeping dude if
you're on a bad mattress it is terrible
you gotta just Helix is the best
mattresses on planet Earth here's the
thing you everybody sleeps differently
everybody has a different mattress
experience okay how long you had your
mattress how was your sleep has it
improved all right do my kids sleep on
Helix mattresses they sent two matches
for the kiddos these little dudes snooze
hard there's a reason why they're
monsters
Helix has 14 unique mattresses including
a collection of luxury models a mattress
for Big and Tall sleepers like Brendan
and even a mattress made just for kids
okay so how do you know it's gonna work
for your body you take the Helix sleep
quiz and find your perfect mattress in
under two minutes and your personalized
mattress is shipped straight to your
door free of charge
trial and then 10 to 15 year warranty
depending on the Helix sleep mattress
you get think about that you can sleep
in it for a hundred nights if you don't
like it this is crazy Helix is offering
you guys up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for the
listeners of fighting the kid go to
helixsleep.com fighter this is their
best offer yet it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now
good night sweet prince
yeah uh anyway your head to Austin buddy
heading to Austin I'll see Mr Rogan
there he's going to take me in a little
tour of the mothership oh
you're not performing though maybe I
need to jump on I don't know that'd be
good talk to Adam Megan about it maybe I
will but then you're just there you but
you're not doing stand-up you're doing a
thing doing a mines Fest where I'm going
to be doing a podcast with Destiny
yep and uh I think Tim Poole I know and
and uh and we're gonna be talking about
the Twitter files oh dude it's gonna be
a debate it's going to be a debate about
the Twitter huh
are you a fainting goat right now come
on don't be a fan no no because I
haven't heard about Twitter thousand
oh God hey can you guys go over January
6th well I think it's going to be a
debate though some people are going to
say it's not so bad and other people are
going to say it is so bad [__] yeah dude
I'll be those tickets
you should make merch it's at the Vulcan
that'd be fun
it'll be fun dude Texas's car isn't it
everybody will see you go out there when
it's hot let's see how everybody I
talked to is talking Texas though you
know because everybody's afraid that
California is going to go just by the
wayside but they've said that for us how
long they've been saying that since
they've been my father said since day
one they've been saying that since the
70s about California always they've been
saying that people hit a winner 70s
that's a fact now are we winning
weather-wise yes yeah weather-wise we
are
people find crime no people find their
way
yeah I don't know what the answer is I
don't know
it's a big decision
yeah
but we weren't the kind of jump while
everyone else jumped but now it looks
like it was a smart move for them
because now that Rogan's club's open
right if you're a comic to Great move
but Austin's definitely comedy Capital
right now yeah right now
yeah
you're gonna have young Innovative
Comics gravitate toward there so if I'm
a comic if I have a dream being a comedy
comic you know I'm gonna figure out a
way to go to no yeah I'm gonna go to
Austin now there's I think I'm right
about that I don't know if you are
because unless you're in with that crowd
what are you gonna get up at
cap City's headline wow whenever you
have whenever you have that many clubs
you're gonna have open bikes yes that's
true because those clubs because
Mothership has open mics I think Sundays
and Mondays Cap City does I don't know
about Vulcan you're gonna have bringer
shows and you're gonna have a lot of
Internet club and then you're gonna have
people that do it like red band has a
club you're gonna have different places
to open those spots get open yeah so it
becomes this whole ecosystem
but if you go out there on Friday and
just don't come back
see you later
my kids would bring me back fire kid and
Margaret met off my kids would bring me
back
or they'd move out there
now we're talking it'd be tough to
uproot a 15 year old oh boy that's
that's a tough time can't do it no all
our friends can't do it your kids are
too old that's different mine are young
where they're like yeah we'll make
friends anymore yours we have real
friendship yeah hey we're leaving why
because it's fun out there that was my
whole childhood I'm not doing that to my
kids no disaster in my my liability is I
was moved literally every year and a
half well that's the number one theme
with everyone in prison right now they
didn't have a home they jumped around I
never I was always moved I told him I my
aunt said I can't believe you're not in
jail or a drug addict I said why because
your childhood was so chaotic it was it
was chaotic just moved all the time ah
we're going to a different continent you
know say bye to your dog some people
turn out all right though I get kids
that do that I did yeah right yeah he
just we didn't turn to the street life
it's also not for you right
right yeah no no I was like let's see
crime I was never going to see that hey
by the way I was loved yeah yeah that's
true yeah I moved around a lot but I
still learned a lot first class yeah
yeah I never went a day without being
hungry and my parents were married yeah
and they loved me yeah and it was a good
relationship and he had good loving I
had no trauma never won a day the only
time I went hungry was when I was
wrestling yeah that was my that was my
phone doing
yeah so he could be in a new city but at
least there was love in that City and
they do say love is for me to complain
me to complain about my childhood
because I moved around a lot is like a
lot of college educated kids complaining
about how unfair and racist Americans
like hey [__] you've never met a
racist and you've never seen any racism
you you you got your education from
Columbia University yeah but you're out
of touch mother yeah you're a catason
privileged Americans yes shut up you're
more emotional about stuff that happened
than they were when it happened to them
back then shut up
yeah you're right dude
um your boots would beg to differ
they've had a rough life I'm I'm getting
older in my workouts I'm not able to
sustain my workouts as much anymore and
it's making me angry time for trt I
gotta I'm thinking about trt calling
shave the head grow the beard like we
talked about maybe a new guy trt Callan
and I get it
my next special is called trt Callan
that's not a bad idea
I'm doing my testosterone my test if you
so my free testosterone was caught up in
the in a binding globule which means
that Propecia was taken caused me a
little problem so no more of that how
long ago but my testosterone is between
650 and 700 accordingly which is solid
at your age yeah super solid that's not
for anybody not bad but there's some
other factors that go into it yeah but
if you're going to do it you got to
commit you know shave the head grow the
beard no okay he's got me things buy
some new he just got me thinking I'll
grow a real beard yeah she looks sick
when he grows the bed
well it again he fights at 35 and he's
you'd say it's thicker than I am
how much do you weighs taller how much
you weigh 170. see cheetahs 150
something yeah 154. that's because he's
in six shape and runs a lot right now
he's okay he's on like fight shape right
now you know yeah but you know that's
getting out of 135 is hard but at 50
he's right where all those guys right
and he's a smaller guy too Sean
O'Malley's 165 laying around so
you could do it with a little help I got
old man oh I saw Super Mario on uh
Saturday
what do you mean saw the movie Super
Mario oh it's [__] good with the kids
with the kids but you know those movies
usually they suck if it's just for kids
but since I well you're older she didn't
grow up playing Super Mario but they
have some throwback things to it it's
fun for adults too hell yeah and when uh
Bowser sings uh the peach song which is
Jack Black I sent to your Griffin like
you need to redo this yourself and dress
up as a giant thick Bowser and it's
gonna go viral when he sings a peach
song dude Crush really Crush dude
Griffin I uh
how what love it first or Love is Blind
my my wife I'm watching that my wife
watched all that when that black dude
sings her a song
so cringy
no all of it's so cringy all of it is so
crunchy I think it's episode you can't
watch I go I can't watch this she made
me watch I've got to episode one or two
where the guy is is his black dude and
this black girl and he's like I finally
found the one he's pulling his pull
pouring his heart and soul on this girl
and she falls asleep and he goes did I
scare you off and she's all
because he can't see he goes
yeah so whenever as I was saying
whenever I talk about like love I always
chase girls away I didn't see that you
know what I'm saying
this always happens and like runs out
and then her friends wake her up and
she's like oh my God that guy was really
weird and smiles a lot and he's like
weirdo I'm only on episode he's on the
Spectrum he can't read people so he's
like see on American Idol if they're in
the the they're cutting it they're doing
the top 24 now so they're cutting half
the audience so tonight's the final cut
for the top 24 but there's a kid with
horrible like anxiety autism and he
started freaking out before one of the
big shows I'm like listen it is what it
is but you can't have the kid go through
Hollywood like he's just not built for
it he's been a great songwriter you
can't go through social media oh dude
because you know that they're gonna just
they're they're safe that's just one I
think about these people on Love is
Blind who are some of them have they're
not gorgeous they they they're they are
regular looking people so I said my girl
I go why would they pick more attractive
people in the show they're regular
looking people and you know they get the
women especially get picked apart by the
way some women the women are better than
the guys but for the guys like love is
ugly apparently Jesus Christ they're not
yes there's something you're like Jesus
they're not that attractive there's a
lot of the white guy with just that bell
pepper knows you're all yeah dude yeah
[__] yeah you're doing behind the wall
I didn't want to say it a bell peppers I
just can't figure it out I don't know
what's happened you know well I do oh
God that's so tough I know man I know
there's all kinds of problems going on
yeah those high definition cameras don't
do anybody any favors and they have
close-ups of their butts and you're like
oh man that that the kid with autism on
American Idol he's really talented at
like Savant playing the piano sure and
he can write music he just he doesn't
sing very well at all yeah and I'm like
how long are you gonna carry this kid on
and get the autism it's been a fun story
but this competition then last night
finally they cut him but as they cut him
uh to put uh autism American Idol
um but but this year's this one oh no
that's him up top there
yeah that's him super talented but as
they cut him it was a soft hit his soft
blow because
um Lionel Richie goes here's the thing
vocally you're just not on the level of
everybody else here because it's the
most talented class we've ever had which
is true he goes but we want to write a a
um Lionel Richie goes I want to write a
song with you you're so good oh wow and
he goes I'm telling you leave here my
office is going to call you we're gonna
collab on a song so he's like it's good
and bad he's like this is cool that's
cool but you see him it's like oh this
kid should not be in front of cameras
you can't handle it just because he you
know he now he overcame it which is
super Brave Hollywood as a guy who went
through Hollywood
yeah
it is so ruthless and the other thing is
when I was younger I was kind of cute I
was I was up for cute guys I was up for
uh you know it was cute guy in his 20s
in a suit I was cute but then you see
cute dad is Hollywood cute and then you
get there and you go and I would go
every one of these guys is a little
taller a little better looking good
morning yeah Bradley Cooper was the
classic before he was famous he was just
a little taller a little more gold a
little Bluer in the eye twinkle in his
eyes just better look it was yeah and
before he was famous if we were standing
with a bunch of girls they didn't notice
me yeah that's just the way it goes
sometimes that's Hollywood yeah since
kids are learning that but they told
them that they're like you know as far
as like on stage performing he was like
you're a great songwriter like right now
you could sell music right now you have
a living making music it's just not
gonna be in front of the camera listen
you can make a fortune writing songs
there's more money in writing 100 that's
it he could kill it that's what Lionel
told him I met a woman who thought I was
gorgeous and she was a songwriter very
successful blind she may have been she
well I was younger and I we had dinner
and I had my beard before I got broke
gray and I had a black shirt black
jacket I was handsome and she said to my
friend she goes she locked in on me
and she was a very successful song I
like made millions millions millions
songs you would know yes like wrote for
the biggest acts and she was
and I remember thinking to myself you
know
she just missed to me just I just wasn't
attracted to her but she was attractive
but just you know but I remember
thinking
how much easier kept man yeah I'll be a
sugar baby yeah because you could see
she wanted to marry me yeah you can see
some why some guys waved the white flag
in the shirt 100 I get it dude I had a
cardiologist you just wake up and feel
like a [__] I was a young man I was 22
and a cardiologist said I will be she
was 34. she goes you can do anything you
want I'll pay all the bills and just be
my man and I was like
no well for like for the first six
months you'd be like this is so dope and
then you have like the the opening House
Barbecue and your buddy's like dude this
place is sit how the [__] are you a
foreign
will lose their respect for you after a
while said one of them really just want
to own you or or they cheat on you with
other high-value males do you know that
yeah because that's what they're
attractive to yeah
you're you're all reliable at home
and then they're working with higher
you know bent over the desk no you might
as well be a plastic [__] doll yeah
that's all you do is open your mouth
can't do it it's like those sugar babies
too it's like I admire guys who can do
it
I don't have any respect for them I
think it's been cool for a bit but then
it's like I don't mean I admire that I
just maybe I'm saying I'm a little
envious of the fact that they're not
competitive enough to worry about you
would be envious for like the first week
and then once you did it like oh this
sucks yeah let's take a little break
because the NBA Playoffs is here and my
Denver Nuggets are the number one seed
in the west but baby so if you want to
bet on my nuggets do it with draftking
Schwartz book an official sports betting
partner the NBA get in on the excitement
of every game with a touch of a button
new customers can bet five dollar
pregame money line bet and score 150
dollars and bonus bonus bets if your
team wins plus everyone can score a no
sweat same game parlay every day during
the NBA Playoffs open the DraftKings
Sportsbook app opt-in and place the same
game partly on any NBA game if it
doesn't hit you'll get a bonus bet back
up to ten dollars again my nuggets
number one seed in the west I think on
the East there's gonna be a real Battle
Royale between the Celtics and the
Milwaukee boots download the app now and
sign up with the code fighter new
customers can take can take just five
dollar pregame moneyline bet and score
150 in bonus bets if your team wins only
at draftking Sportsbook with a code
fighter 100 800 1-800 Gambler
Massachusetts call
1-800-327-5050 or visit gamblinghelp.com
in New York call 8778 Hope e and hope n
y or text Hope and why
467-369 Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino Resort KS 21 plus in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction did you know that yes
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com Sportsbook for details
and state-specific responsible gambling
resources draftkings.com I've seen about
that the other day I was watching True
Blood and the guy owns a strip club in
there oh my God that'd be cool man I'm
like but to him that's just life on my
face [__] going to work yeah and first
like I'll be so sick like no I know it's
like race car drivers some guys crazy
money would you say some guys marry into
crazy money Jackie Malouf you know yeah
so her husband who is on botched a
really cool guy I love them yeah they
wanted to do my ears no they did they
want to fix me what's his name
I love the guy well I had dinner with
him and I just got along with him he's
just a great guy
and he's Lebanese and he's just a really
successful no it's another name no type
in The Botch doctors yeah
but one guy's had so much he was just a
cool dude I got along with you know but
he was I remember he said something
interesting yeah that guy that guy which
one the guy
yeah Paul Nassif Dr Paul Nasser I loved
him we really we got along great really
cool guy so he looks identical get ready
he looks identical for the in the movie
The Mask when the bad guy gets the mask
bring it up chin the bad guy and the man
the bad guy in the movie The Mask from
the 90s that's a bad picture no that's
him that's how he likes with all that
he's married is he yeah yeah remarried a
younger lady and they have a baby
together but either way he's uh he was I
liked him he's one of us just a cool
dude he seems great but he said he was
he was married to there he is to the
malus there he is okay
such an old school reference
wealthy you know family and he said he
goes he was talking about the house and
he goes I don't know the house is so big
I don't even there's some rooms I
haven't even been in something like
slight Flex it well no he wasn't even
saying it that way so money right he's a
plastic surgeon makes no money but he
was saying Super Famous he was like he
was like if you if the context was
something about where is it because I
don't know because I I don't know the
house is so big you know he moved into
that house it wasn't his house yeah and
he wasn't it it was too big a house like
sometimes into a mansion well he married
him well he just flexing a little bit no
he's like yeah dude my dick's exhausted
you know he's like oh it hurts so much
to do I don't know what to do he just
married into crazy money but he had
money already that's what I'm saying so
after a while though like it's like this
plastic surgery money good money and
then there's that money and I don't know
but after certain threshold right
there's nowhere to go that's what I mean
all right well once your bills are fine
and you can make investment stuff it's
all the same right correct and that's
and then there's a different level where
like a billionaire where you're like you
know flying on rockets and [__] and
buying exotic pets I don't know yeah
then you have to worry about giving it
away or how to make the world a better
place I don't know that'd be my problem
give me a billion dollars you know what
I do I go okay God put me in this
position now I have to make the world a
better place and I would panic no you do
what you do what most billionaires do
and go this is insane we're in a
simulation it's like yeah well the
single mother of three at Walmart
doesn't think is the simulation only
billionaires think we're in simulation
yes it's insane well that's that old
saying it's like you think you have
problems until somebody punches you in
the face you think words are violence
until somebody actually does violence to
you I love that in college you know
that's the thing right that your words
yeah that you know that's a that's how
those weird things yeah so so your words
are harmful so they want speech laws
that's why in Canada they want speech
laws they want they literally want
Canada dictatorship because I don't know
if you realize they passed have you seen
the new [__] they've passed yes it's
getting weird yes so so it's for them
the argument is my words make you
uncomfortable because the physiological
change in your body and so therefore
it's violence and and anybody who says
that has never experienced real violence
yeah okay
okay getting punched in your face or
kicked in the [__] head might be a
little different
so if when when Izzy was like you're a
dick leave me alone that wouldn't have
stopped that doesn't stop him what does
is turning turning Kaka
yeah what do you got Jed
alrighty
the first one is kind of crazy not kind
of crazy it's super crazy is this 19
year old girl who's accused of having
sex with dogs okay on camera okay and
only if you look at her she's actually
she's actually attractive Right girls
who are hold on go up to him let me read
the whole headline go for it it says
Mississippi woman who's 19 accused of
sex with German shepherd is pictured
with the dog after she crashed her car
days before arrest cops say bestiality
tape was recorded outside local Baptist
Church so she apparently it was recorded
outside of a church she's saying that
someone forced her to do it but uh
there's multiple videos and they there's
a three other dogs involved as well so
this is what this what happened
but this before she was arrested though
but why why would you be arrested for
[__] a dog because that's specialty
it's illegal oh it is yeah
okay that's her she's really cute I mean
you can't see her but that's her again
uh can I just say that that I don't
groove of dogs
can I say I don't approve of people
[__] dogs but I don't approve of
having her life ruined over this so the
dog is that's a life sentence right
dog's [__] her she's not [__] well
you know what I'm saying I guess but
that's a life sentence so that problem
with social media is that your whole
life is over because you had some weird
fetish but I I I get the social media
backlash for hooking up with dogs 10
years in prison like that Society
she won't do it any time yeah and we
still have to adopt a dog but that's a
tough one for her because that's maybe
she's a little bit emotionally off
either way when you do this and you have
a picture everywhere your her life is
over and I I think that's [__] up
there has to be some consequences though
though but also the difference she was
raping the dog yeah
you know that's a weird thing but that's
how I feel too like if the dog's [__]
her then it's kind of like I agree it's
so different than you [__] the dog I
don't know why it's so [__] there's
somebody in their butts or in their
yeah in their vagina is different than
letting somebody [__] you yeah just is
exactly so that's if you're like here's
my ass you you can't if I might I say
hey you want to bang me you're not
traumatized you have to get your dick
well it'd be pretty trauma well I'm just
saying that I'd have to really convince
you yeah with my violent words more than
peanuts that dog was happiest and I made
you do it that's different but I'm
saying that dog
was into it most like I mean
you're gonna lock her up I had a great
time yes right that dog was into it
so she's saying that someone forced her
but then the investigation's still
ongoing but they think that's uh someone
paid her like you know like yeah
she could do that so she was making
videos for them and then the videos got
leaked goddamn real money it's kind of
sad because how bad do you need money
girl you're letting this pit bull put
his whistle probably into it maybe some
people get off I don't know maybe or or
is a lot of money there's a friend of
mine she her girlfriend here we go her
friend put peanut butter on her coochie
and used to let her I feel sick
fainting goat syndrome oh fainting goats
her Crumpet
or Crumpet a bearded clam at your age
don't say coochie at your age what are
you Gucci man okay oh God I don't know
her muff whose friend did you have that
did this uh I she was friends best
friend there wasn't even only fans she
was doing because she's a freak she was
over at her friend's house and her
friend goes watch this put peanut butter
on her friends and her friend my friend
was like
um this is very strange but I bet that
late that girl could still get a
boyfriend right the guys don't give a
[__] 100 she's hot enough I know hey
guys leave her alone dude she [__] the
dog okay that's what'll happen uh are
you with uh don't say it bro yeah she
won't get 10 years but I wonder what
gives you what gets you 10 years for
bestiality I think when you depend on
you harm an animal if it's a guy [__]
a dog well when you do that when you
torture animals and stuff like that but
that's not bestiality bro it's sex with
the animals Joey I don't think I don't
think even that but if you rape a dog
that's torch to the dog yeah so I would
say that would be worse yeah my friend
was a cop in San Francisco there we go
and caught a guy [__] a chicken under
a towel in his car his throat doesn't
make sense he was [__] the chicken in
the beak in the where they where they
lay eggs
was like I don't really want to arrest
him for this and his partner was like
we're arresting him well I wouldn't
arrest someone like his life's not going
now it's like okay you want to rest and
put him in prison because he he's
already dude he's on the street yeah I
eat chickens so I I can't say that
[__] a chicken is any worse so if I
was a chicken I'd rather get [__] than
eaten
yeah I don't know man you understand
what it's like yeah
people [__] animals yeah but I do want
to know what's going to get you 10 years
like the maximum prison sentence I don't
know you want me to look it up
bestiality
this is already a shadow band yeah
all right
Georgie a couple of three kids discover
their cousins after 10 years I mean look
at them
yeah this couple uh distant cousins yes
distance distant cousins they discovered
they are cousins from about eight
Generations ago ah big deal yeah
um worth it they went out and made a
tick tock about this to share their
story oh they shouldn't done that yeah
that is that's dicey uh yeah I feel like
that's a interesting cousins from eight
from like eight generational apart yeah
so far away
they did one of the tests you know the
DNA test to find out that yeah it's like
you have Ramirez you have romance that'd
be a little weird but what are you gonna
do you have kids you're like does it
change anything do you but don't you
have to worry about if they do have kids
if they have kids it's like a first
cousin yeah because then you got to
worry about getting in touch yeah but
they said their kids are all fine have
all their fingers and toes it's just
genetic anomalies that can happen
purified I feel like if you're like from
an island or something that's very
common like yeah well so they say
something to the effect of when a kid so
you ever knows how teenagers become
rebellious they don't want to talk to
their parents apparently there is a
there is a a biological evolutionary
reason for that the daughter your
daughter your son hates you you know and
they want to get the hell away from you
they want to go hang out with their
friends that would be the idea of I'm
going over to that Clan over there
because that's that that's where the
genetic variance is If I Stay within my
own village I'm gonna have sex with
somebody who I'm most likely related to
whoa so there's an idea that I gotta get
all the way over there and then when
they're 25 they come back to you
interesting yeah that would be the the
anthropological explanation for why
teenagers hate their parents
well that's good all right next one is a
YouTuber I don't know if you guys watch
YouTube much but there's a lot of prank
videos they're very popular I hate them
personally I don't like it yeah I don't
like it though so this YouTuber was
trying to make a prank video in a in a
mall and he kept harassing this guy and
the guy pulled out a gun and shot him
those stupid games Win stupid prizes
there you go especially in today's
climate like what are you doing how bad
is this guy so he's fine he's gonna make
it where do you get shot I think uh
gallbladder where's the gallbladder oh
yeah
they say that's the worst spot to get
hit going on yeah [__] yeah and then all
the toxins get out you're harassing that
guy I know the Stewie eyes and then he I
guess he walked up to with the phone
camera and said like you smell you smell
like whatever you smell bad or something
like that and then kept her out what was
the prank though it's just doing that
bothering people a chalk Factor stupid
to see what the guy's gonna do and this
guy's like look at my [__] haircut
dude I'm gonna shoot you he does look
like someone that would change someone
can I see what he said can I read it uh
I mean there's no like actual because
it's just hearsay but antagonizes yeah
uh targeter targeted harass accosted and
followed
but yeah what I read is like he said
something like you smell and he wanted
to get his reaction
now I don't think you should be able to
just shoot people because they're
harassing no they're both might be
better to just punch him in the face but
that not this would have never happened
if that dumbass YouTuber was it
harassing the guy so yeah give him a
little bit of leniency there also look
at him
right
yeah let me see what the prosecution
she's so sleepy
uh against a very concerning charge as
cook says he was shot by suspect
yeah yes the prosecution is trying to go
after the YouTuber because he was
harassing by the way these YouTube
pranksters they do a lot of [__] that
would dude we would get in fights I'm
sure everyone here would get into a
fight over the stuff yeah some people
put buckets over people's heads randomly
well I saw this kid get Molly whopped on
Worldstar he's at Home Depot it's this
big dude yeah he like goes behind him
and goes ah like slam something the guy
he thought it was a shot grabs kid and
just [__] Stone Cold Steve Austin
slams him on thing knocks a kid out it's
like I appreciate it that's how this
goes I appreciate that nobody's up to
your YouTube [__]
yeah I hit that stupid prank stuff that
guy [__] around find out that's the
picture that's a mascot right there [__]
around find out sleepy sleepy so tired
so bothered he has to sleep in prison
tonight yep just like oh God
uh all right so I don't know much about
NBA but this guy Rudy you know the
nuggets are number one team in the west
hell yeah did not know that the center
from the uh Minnesota Timberwolves Rudy
gobert who was also the one that got in
trouble with the kovitz stuff do you
remember that Cody he's like I don't
worry about it he touched all the mics
the next day oh people were furious at
him because they're asking about he's
like I'm not worried about this look at
this
walks off next day Rudy out of the game
yeah
during the final game of the season on
his new team the Timberwolves him and a
teammate got into a scuffle and threw
punches at each other yeah
[__] I'm gonna turn down the volume
here it sounds like really say I'm about
to slap you look at him
which one is which you'll see there boom
and then runs away
in the middle of a game game yeah Tommy
I know and they're teammates yeah yeah
that's never good that doesn't make
sense Rudy's such a good player though
multiple time defense Yeah well yeah
right yeah yeah but still that's a
little strange but then again maybe that
guy was in his face with too much I
don't know sometimes [__] happens
sometimes [__] guys a lot of alpha males
on one team should start going well and
there's a way to talk and there's a way
not to after the game another player
punched a wall and broke his hand too
okay Minnesota's in turmoil yeah they're
in turmoil
all right this is a
uh
punch in the chest too he's a push
update on the Dylan Mulvaney partnership
thing with uh Bud Light dealing with any
of the now trans person
so since that happened I guess social
media on Bud Lights either their
Instagram and Twitter has been silent
completely have you seen the backlashes
no but have you seen the the woman who
was responsible for this no okay so she
made a video
so she she there's a video of the vice
president of Bud Light marketing and she
basically
said that I was looking Bud light's been
a Brand that's been failing people have
been drinking as much of it is there it
is
and she was inspired to update the
fratty out of touch
and it's like darling
Budweiser you're out of touch dude you
don't have any friends that drink
Budweiser and you don't drink Budweiser
how [__] is she well it's just this is
the thing hey [__]
you can't hire somebody that doesn't
drink the beer or isn't part of the
culture
okay
okay go back for a sec can you go back
to what Rapinoe say wrapping up where go
up go up go up up no I'm sorry down down
let me just see what I want to go down
go down please right there oh super
among athletes who signed their opposing
protection of girl opposing protection
of girls you're off topic brother we
have no idea
because we're literally talking about
yeah let's talk about that I want to get
into the Mega Man all right we'll go
that afterwards all right all right but
she's ruined the brand like because
they're they're main core audience is
just so repulsed by all this so they're
out well because you gotta hope that it
pays off who drinks Budweiser what are
you doing oh no you're dead so let's
know what she says here she's it's
interesting did you see it yeah yeah
basically she said I was looking to
create an inclusive bright
uh bright uh you know message it's like
you are so out of touch she calls she
calls the fratty thing out of touch no
you're out of touch you don't know
anybody that drinks Budweiser you don't
know anybody who listens to sports radio
you don't know anybody that works with
their hands you don't know which is most
of the middle class America that's
drinking Bloodlines she comes from
college
in a real world she comes from an area
code that hires those people and doesn't
but you also tailoring towards the one
percent which you can't make a business
off of the only time she has contact is
when she calls a guy to fix her car or
whatever you see that that Mulvaney is
new her new thing although it's a dude
still her new thing is tampons
I got no problem with Mulvaney that's
just a business person that business
person wants to do it and funny and got
to care
get your money girl that's it I'm saying
I don't have any problem with Dylan
Mulvaney I that I actually find that
person hilarious good time you know that
you know muffini was a I believe was in
Book of Mormon really talented uh uh
musical theater person yeah so when I
heard when she was a he
um I believe that he was one of the cast
mates look at this how about that you
know how talented you have to be for
that
I mean she seems very sorry
you're talking about somebody who's just
who's just cashing checks it's it's
these out of touch corporations where
it's like what did you think was gonna
happen yeah that's like because because
they're feeling the feeling the water
out on social media and then they're
like oh [__] this went South so fast
there's no really coming back from it as
a brand like Bud Light there's not no
like those people that are hardcore like
the middle class America which makes it
the majority of America you're [__]
man we'll see if they stick to it
because people tend to be damage is done
you think so Amazon's done yeah because
now if they go all right we released
Mulvaney well then the Uproar of social
media woke
starts coming for you so then that's a
whole nother problem I think you just
don't say anything like they're doing uh
my bad hey check out this new frat pack
or whatever the [__] distraction or
just keep doing your thing I mean by
wise I'll be fine Budweiser is here to
stay but Anheuser-Busch yeah yeah but
they're they're definitely probably
gonna
take a small hit she said what do you
want me to do we're a dying brand like
hey [__] yeah you're doing so much
damage to us worst hire ever yeah oh
yeah what else you got all right Georgie
so on the most recent Mandalorian
episode from Star Wars uh celebrity
appearance lizzo and Jack Black were a
space royalty couple that's pretty cool
Jack Black is so good in uh Super Mario
Jack Black doesn't miss
I don't watch those uh Star Wars but
people either yeah Liza's pretty badass
isn't she
yeah what do you think
she uh it was just a very random
celebrity appearance like there wasn't I
like those one those random like you
know Kim Kardashian has a big role in
the new
um American American Horror Story which
is my favorite series how
flu player she kind of flew yeah Flutie
I think that's what they call him
fluties right loudest loudest oh yeah
food to tear yes uh early life and
education how old is she
sorry
Liz bangers okay yeah she got big
what does
let me see here oh so you know Easter
was just yesterday and there was a
parade
in Spain and sadly the Virgin Mary
caught on fire during the parade and
people were freaking out that's
obviously that's a sign so I mean did I
tell you
so one of the candles had a bunch of
candles on that oh that makes sense of
scandals yeah but I mean just the
symbolism the the fact that this
happened there Lucifer is here that's
our world in 2023 right now
I love the Spaniards they get crazy holy
[__] someone put out the goddamn fire
they tried so if two of the guys tried
they put tried it with their hands and
one of them tried to blow on the fire
hell yeah smart
quickly put out with this gasoline young
kids like you know I had a very dude did
you see the Dalai Lama oh yeah no that
was no you didn't see him on Twitter he
got so bad the backlash was so bad he'd
come out they had to be like hey he's
always nice seeing kids you're missing
the context there dude it is the
creepiest thing you will see all year oh
my God no you gotta you gotta go to
Twitter and get the real video because
they edit it because the mainstream
someone has the the raw footage dude
this kid comes up he puts his hand near
his crotch he's touched him and he goes
suck my tongue the little kid is like
put you on stage the weirdest [__]
you've ever seen
this isn't like some Sam tripley [__]
here this is real [__] Brian oh my God
look where he puts his hand
did you ask for a kiss
which is weird from the chop then look
ask them to suck his tongue
the kid's like okay man
very strange no watch this no I can't
wait for the weirdest part
I would
suck my tongue oh my
God if you're a parent I'd be like I
don't give a [__] who that is check out
this Showtime Pettis jumping kick off
your stupid desk old man
that is so strange nothing to see here
he's a good guy nothing to see what do
you think that is
it there's a word for this Brian
all right can I see something with a
hard P there's no way to defend it if
any man asked my son to suck his tongue
hey I don't care who it is they do this
you put your hand there no no no no no
no
um though it got so bad because people
were like uh what's happening here some
someone some represented was like oh
like look at his apology no they got
taken out contacts okay no no no it's
very easy to read it's done very
publicly
you're the Dalai Lama dude you're
untouchable
you need to look into the Dalai Lama I
don't know what to say about that I know
Chris Hansen should be somewhere around
there and go you want to have a seat oh
you already are perfect
yeah you want me to suck your tongue I'm
sorry Dolly you you want me to suck your
child because I'm of age you want me to
suck your tongue oh you don't want me to
you want a little Billy here to do it
is that what you're saying yeah how
weird is that
it's a guy doesn't have kids
yeah defend it
defend it defend it
hold on
yeah bring up the statement that his
team put out you're like okay I just end
up dying I think that that would just
make me want to go like this uh well if
I'm Dalai Lama like that's computer
generated no I wasn't even there two
defecty fake
let's see let's see the full he's 87. at
87 he doesn't even know there's cell
phones out
sure his Holiness often teases people he
meets an innocent playful way even in
public before cameras he regrets this
incident
where was the joke where yes a young boy
to suck your tongue I'm waiting for the
punchline dolly he's like so old too but
he probably doesn't realize people he's
being recorded he's just doing that [__]
because that's what he oh he's never
even heard of Bud Light that that that
is more cringy than that black guy on
Blind Date singing to his girl yeah you
guys seen this girl on Monday is funny
that's why I watch it yeah this terrible
as a parent you should be outraged
that's like a Joe Biden moment yeah I'll
give you my tongue if you saw a conehead
I'm just it also sucks
even if the hottest girl in the world
was like suck my tongue up like oh no
I'll do it but that's so weird yeah I've
never
if you're like
the way he did it too though he's like
puts his time yes oh and you think it's
his first time having a kid suck I know
anything on his body
at 87. she didn't give a [__] how weird
is that
Brian don't know what to do
87 87.
yeah okay that was terrible give back
away from kids
oh all right so moving on Utah is the
first U.S state to limit teen social
media access so they basically if you
want to use like Tick Tock or whatever
social media and you're a kid you have
to get parentals you know sign off at if
you're under 18. kids can just a forge
that [__] though I don't know how it
works but doesn't China do this too with
the kids on tickets they limit like
certain types of time periods yeah
that's cool
it's a real problem I know we're gonna
do I know anyone not addicted to their
phone like I I don't know I know handful
of people have out alcohol issues or
cigarettes or I don't know a single
person that's not addicted to their
phone
not a single song we get off the show
Brian's on Tick Tock I'm not
all the time I'm not it's weird right
you know it's true like if my my dad you
know he's 64. he's not on social media
but he's on his phone reading the news
just can't see on there just can't see
on there my mother 82 is like this she's
on Tick Tock this is amazing
there's so many entertaining things I'm
like get off she's like look at the dog
alone it's cool
yeah yeah it's weird because I don't
know how they're going to control it
it's smart there should be something
they can do but
I don't know I think what happens though
I don't know about you but like with
anything if you watch like you start
getting
um a bad feeling from watching it like I
get if I'm watching Snow's not
productive it's also doesn't make me
feel good like it makes me feel like my
brain's getting cooked and once you
start realizing that you stop doing it
like I don't do it anymore because I
don't like the way it makes me feel
yeah you still do it I really don't what
on Instagram well nothing reals you
don't think you're on social media at
all really not not much come on I don't
I don't watch uh Tick Tock I'm not on
Tick Tock I don't have Tick Tock yeah
but I'll watch like if I'm on YouTube
though YouTube has those reels so I'll
go to look at something and I'll be like
well let me so I'll watch you know
there's a big push there's a big push
with uh younger kids they're getting
flip phones
yeah why is that because like anti this
what we're doing because the Smart Ones
know it's going on a bad Road I sit my
daughter I would need a tick tock from
her phone oh yeah I would love to get a
flip phone just the the only problem is
pictures my kids why you swim with my
wife and use her phone
it'd be cool yeah
Dana uses a flip phone still
to this date didn't you just flip phone
Dana White Dana Dana what Dana White
white does no kidding
well sketching
all right let's do this one real quick
this has Ben Affleck
speaking Spanish did you guys know he
speak Spanish fluent yeah no he's so
good at Spanish so it's going viral this
video is going viral yeah he's
ridiculous at it let me hear it at least
for a while because my girl brought it
up and I was like Ben Affleck
[Music]
no idea video girl there it is no it's
not a picture it's like impeccable my
girl said like
Flawless Spanish really
where do you learn Spanish
well obviously from JLo as well
nah my girl speaks Spanish you don't
pick up [__] with that but he probably
does not even fluent in Spanish I don't
think is she she's fluent but she's not
like it's not it's not her first
language
it might as well be bands that's itching
that you keep doing no it doesn't load
them don't let you refresh you just type
in Ben Baptist speaking Spanish and pop
up everywhere
wait George you sent me something
yeah I said
isn't that crazy well he's [__] his
accent's great yeah so my girl said she
doesn't sound like a white boy I'm
talking Spanish sounds like this
[__] grew up in Mexico
it's crazy huh impressive
that's awesome
uh one more how many more give me one
more all right one more this is an
awesome story so there's a woman that's
according to the article spent her life
savings to pay for her daughter's cancer
treatment breast cancer and then
literally the day if you know people
that are cancer patients if they if you
know they they can make it past it they
run the Bell yeah they ring a bell when
they leave the hospital yeah uh so
literally the day after she rung the
Bell her mom won two million dollars on
a scratcher that's so cool yeah I'm
gonna have to attack stuff she took the
she took the one lump Sun so 1.6 million
a lot of money she should do that's so
dope yeah it's a great story
that's huge being cancer again two mil
not a bad idea I could spend all our
money on her daughter yeah it's great
well uh I will be with the Dalai Lama
Atlanta this Thursday Friday Saturday
Atlanta come get you some get those
peaches out do the Dirty Bird Shuffle
Atlanta April 13th and 15th La Jolla
comic store June 2nd through the 4th
before that September 29th through
October 1st Brian and I at skank Fest a
few tickets left that's gankfest.com and
then I'm over in Europe UK Dublin so
that starts June 15th it's a theater run
so one show only in every single City
Belfast Glasgow uh Manchester London
Cardiff Dublin get your tickets thick
boy.com Dublin Cardiff see you at Helium
uh we got uh um April 20th to the 22nd
in Portland Comedy Zone Port Charlotte
Florida the Sunday theater May 4th to
the May 6th and then Stress Factory New
Brunswick New Jersey May 11th to the
13th are you doing that thing at Vulcan
too right yeah no it's a Vulcan mine's
Fest yeah all right kids love you see ya